edgar this is the most
requested video i had in a long time
also
crisp camera quality is it i don't know
let's hope so
it's pewdiepie being a minecraft veteran
for 10 minutes straight
for those of you who don't know i have
about
i did a minecraft series uh how long has
it been a year ago two years
and i knew nothing about the game but i
had played it when it was just
out so i pretended i mean i didn't
pretend i knew
how to put that i knew how to play the
game but now that i've sunk like
i don't know 400 hours in the game uh i
wanted to react
to my mistakes and heavily suggested by
you guys to see if
it resonates sort of uh the dull mastery
why does he not open
i didn't know you had to use splint and
steel i guess i forgot that that's funny
because that was definitely in the
original version
excuse me i thought this was all i had
to do maybe it needs to be night
maybe it has to be night that'd be kind
of cool you have to lit the portal at
night mo jang hey you could learn some
stuff from this
find flint i play the game how do i find
flynn
i don't i mean that's not very intuitive
isn't it
you know i'm sort of a veteran i don't
need you kids to tell me how to play
minecraft
i know how to play minecraft so how do i
build
a twig what the [ __ ] is a twig i mean a
steak
why do i want to make a stick you
haven't even made a crafting table yet
why are you making sticks dude
there it is i got it oh my god the
crafting table yeah
all right sort is like uh yeah that
looks like a sword right
[Laughter]
that's a sword it would make sense if
maybe these were at the bottom at least
i don't know
where's this recipe oh okay uh sword oh
he does it for you can i kill you
[Laughter]
don't mess with iron golems ever ever
unless you're a minecraft veteran
like i am no they don't look that strong
i was generally shocked how fast i died
now we built the furnace that's right
did i build it or what
yeah you build it without any of the
materials good
congratulations felix i feel like i have
to pause so much in this i'm doing
everything wrong
you're doing everything wrong iron which
we make from
iron ore and charcoal i'm looking in the
furnace settings oh my god what is this
then that's just coal
well how do you make you can still use
coal charcoal
from lava bucket what
jungle wood now what that this is so
complicated
i thought you needed all of these things
i was like what
just to melt iron any what
i can make a smithing table what
no i understand i get it now
oh it comes there we go get hiccup and
you don't need that table
in a long time felix but it's all this
what do i do on this i like how i didn't
even right click
i left click it great goddammit
the classic moment right here where i tr
i didn't understand how
oh jesus stop
see god damn it i didn't understand how
to litter tnt so i thought it made sense
to let a tnt with a torch
first i tried hitting it because i
thought that would make sense like you
act debate it no how do i make it boom
how do i make it boom
[Music]
i mean i get that it's a redstone
component but it's not obvious that it
is
right god damn it his knowledge gets
reset every time he creates a new world
yeah it's easy to forget all the
minecraft stuff there's a lot of things
to know to be
to be fair and sometimes when people ask
me about minecraft now
i i don't even feel proud about it i'm
like why do i know all this
how do i blow it maybe we can plant the
eggs
so to make a fork maybe you can plant
the eggs
and you can go through portals and
nethers and deem air like it doesn't
make sense why would i not be able to
plant the lake
i stand by planting the leg egg egg egg
you need the hoe and you hit the top
that does not work i spent six hours
watching minecraft tutorials why is it
not working
you have to right click my dude oh man
you see the frustration in his eyes he's
watched six hours of tutorials
and they didn't tell you to right click
maybe i need to plant the hole
i need to plant the whole what do i do
with the hoe now i can plant the seed
no you can't oh i i
love how i'm so confidently wrong
i'm so sure oh this is so
right click yeah what happened to you
why are you naked
whoa it's a wide chest it's even bigger
oh you shift click and it just oh my god
that is so much easier
yeah that is exactly jack just growing
pirate wait
[Music]
the [ __ ] cactus bro eat
you're gonna die wear it wear it you're
the guy
maybe apple maybe he wants apple you
want the apple
you want that what horses like apples
minecraft
mojang i'm calling you out come on
[Music]
all right fine so here's the thing i i
still learned like just a couple months
ago
i thought you needed to feed them to
obtain them but you don't you just have
to sit on them
and uh have nothing in your left hand i
think
not sure if that's true or not i think
so i thought you had to feed them wheat
for the longest time i was so sure about
it i know this because i'm
actually a veteran at minecraft a lot of
hey look at that i know how to make
buckets all right
what is that nugget i can't say that bad
word
we just have to dig straight down bros
now we take a book
yeah always dig straight down i stand by
that get water and we pour it in the
lava
how do i do that
it hasn't hit him yet the realization
that he's gonna have to go all the way
back up to get some more water
got him then i also have to be far away
no way did i get it
how is it possible
maybe it needs to be nice no and you
don't have to fill in the corners
from gravel i did it with my diamond axe
oh the pain
the my diamond rest in peace diamond
pickaxe number one
uh
it rains in minecraft oh my god
i did no you just need one you just need
one
i'm supposed to kill you guys no
definitely not
no no oh god this is it
this is it hello hello i'm talking to
you
don't hit him oh don't look at him
creepy dude
[Music]
why is he not attacking me like this
what
i'm so lucky here i should be dying put
it down
put it down put it down put it down
please eat you have food eating
you just farted i think if i do
this and this wow
it's a red bed now i feel at home could
i actually just capture him with my
bucket
smash like if you're excited for bucket
making time that's what i thought that's
what i thought
i know how to make a bucket
but that's what i thought that's what
[Applause]
that's so unrealistic you're coming with
me in the bucket
right now you can't do that
no it's sad that's another thing i i
think a lot of these
should be used studied by mojang yeah
you should be able to put turtles in
buckets mojang
going in the bucket kitty you're going
in the bucket
i want to make egg cats to be sure
compass can you make compass
i remember making a compass even back in
my day boom boom boom
and then in the middle yeah there's my
compass so why can't i what's the
problem what's the problem with the
compass
i don't get it the fact that peers
remember the old tnt is great what does
that mean
yeah before you could punch it and it
would go boom so give him
the respect that he deserves wait
so i that's so interesting that that was
actually a thing
the fact that he punched him t that's
how you light up tnt in the earlier
version real veteran
real veteran that's right i want my
badge
i cannot breathe underwater we're going
to the nether
because everyone said there's a secret
achievement
if you sleep in the nether oh god i'm
scared
no all right i was so i was so
mad i was legitimately you i knew
something would happen right but you can
see my genuine shots
and also i had i thought redstone blocks
looks cool
it's such a bad idea to use for designs
my own supporters can you believe this
also you don't have to
make the water like uh tell me where is
it
i got like half my stuff help me look
pig
people all right so does the compass
work here
why did i even think to bring my horse
to the nether in retrospect
no this could have been avoided never
bring your horse through the nether
whoa another house another house
everyone
please tell me i investigated it oh i
did okay
and of course and of course oh no
i set off a bomb didn't i
i'm making every mistake you could
possibly make dude
of course i stepped on the trap play
minecraft they said
[Music]
sleep in the nether they said
you could enter there with your horse
they said
yes that's right people told me i
remember you say
you guys killed your again it all comes
back to me now
what is this oh you can't break that
don't do that
because i need the comments to help me
actually i can't trust you why is there
no scuba equipment
true they had nine years to add it can i
zoom in on this
okay i give up whoa what is that
i was so mad there as well i dug for so
[ __ ] long dude
look at this face
yeah it helps to have a better shovel
let me tell you that whoa what is that
what is that like a frog it's dangerous
we're gonna kill the giant
frog thing ah this is bad uh it's all
right i brought
don't panic i actually
[Music]
how is it possible i'm making every
mistake you can make i don't mind i
guess everyone does
right right everyone this is playing
mine my god you can
i'm mining with a melon bros so a lot of
you have been saying that i can put a
name tag on jurgen
and i'm like that's epic yorkie how do i
put names well you have to name the
nametag
you're again enchantment cause what
how do i get that [ __ ] what what does
enchantment cost
what am i paying my soul that's a fair
question to me
it's really interesting watching this
from a fresh perspective of minecraft
then i can get his epic diamond sword
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo profs claim for putting this together
that's hilarious they explode
oh it's ice
no i'm drowning stop it felix stop it
stop it
stop it you're greedy
what if i blow him up don't punch it
all right see you in a bit okay gamer
[Music]
i mean that was pretty epic not gonna
lie i don't
aqua infinity does that mean i can
breathe on the water better
let's try no it doesn't i don't know
what affinity means it means that you
can mine quicker underwater
you want respiration and i have i never
heard the word respiration before
obviously it means something
breathing right respiration yeah i
didn't know that word
you learn english with minecraft gamers
oh it does seem like the bubbles are
different
no no they're not
there's no difference i'm an idiot
potato carrot
okay it's cool how do i come in oh this
is
you just follow me oh my god is he
attacking
go doggy can i give a shield to sven
it's a cat wearing can i give a [ __ ]
does that mean you can wear armor
here's something that we wanted to do
for a long time sven
i'm sorry oh give him his name ty i
thought i lost you
oh yeah i gotta put the name
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this
oh i don't want to see this
oh yeah this is epic what are you doing
swam down with me jurgen jurgen swim up
swim up swim up swim up
no i can't do this i can't see what they
are no
no infinity swim
oh my up so dramatic dude
everyone knows you can eat you can
breathe on the water as long as you're
eating
swim up look i'm almost dying
that was badass dude let's go
i'm a minecraft veteran i don't need you
to tell me what to do also pewdiepie
sleep in the nether achievement
let's go that's hilarious what a fun
throwback to the series man that was
insane
[Laughter]
we've come a long way gamers we've come
a long way
hell yeah that was great thanks for
watching subscribe for every subscriber
i get a subscriber
so thank you see ya